hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey I'm Brad Chandler
Brianne is with us today she just popped
in the neighborhood shot a couple of
podcasts with us and we saw this Netflix
trailer drop so we're like let's do a
reaction why not
that's what people will actually watch
of us so yay hey Brianne before we go
into this trailer of the dirt which is
about Motley Crue oh yeah yeah I'm a
huge Molly Crew friend I wanted to say
thank you to all your beautiful sons of
[ __ ] and bastards who follow us on
our patreon page over there we got so
much [ __ ] weekly q and A's TV show
stream alongs for shows like my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood
I just finished all of attack on Titan
just start up one punch man supernatural
Gotham John's almost fully up to date
with Riverdale and he just started up
the haunting at Hill House and we do
reaction highlights with footage
included for shows like supernatural my
hero academia and one punch man and John
also does plenty of music video coverage
for all you Molly crew fans amazing I'm
a she nailed it a huge Mollie crew fan
man Kid Rock def Carmen Electra Rock
Uncle Kracker
Carmen Electra supergroup so cool man
I'm so excited you guys up to date on
supernatural nope
it could have happened to anybody
dropped in with her but it did it happen
across
[Applause]
nice it's gonna be something nobody's
ever seen before
oh my god was my pants let's talk about
it
[Music]
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] their asses and we've gotta
give him the show I'm talking like a
stage show the club's fans that dying
for some anarchy so let's give it to
I work for like record you guys like a
record you keep safe
[Applause]
and well for pians bon jovi the party
atro kiss
never been
what I know it's an easy guy from
Breaking Bad
[Music]
there's a lot of POVs GoPro shots in her
head
[Music]
weights like this is their response to
Bohemian Rhapsody they're like we can do
this we can do this we can we can show
you the lifestyle I got so much more
about their lifestyle not really
anything about their music exactly I'm
we really appeal to you normally I feel
like what biopics you're just watching
like a bunch of generic creations of
songs that probably didn't go down that
way it seems like it's the opposite you
know like a story like Bohemian Rob see
is like rising from the ashes it's like
you're already there and then you're
just disintegrating into the opposite
story well the funny thing to me is like
most of what I know about Motley Crue is
the life style that they lend much more
than the music cuz they are yeah just
note aureus
wrecking things and debauchery and
really living like the quintessential
rock and roll lifestyle that you would
have associated you know at least back
in the 80s I imagine there was probably
some really dark horrible things that
happened to them due to this type of
lifestyle and again and partying I like
trailers like that yeah I think of like
vice you know it's like oh there's some
terrible things that happen with Dick
Cheney but this trailer makes it look
cool this is like that wolf of
wallstreet vibe of just man look how
much fun it looks like to be these guys
if there's probably some major downfall
I don't know anything about their
personal lives or their story you know
he's the one who comes out on top the
other three members died maybe yeah not
before making that same family they're
gonna cover that I hope they explore
that I didn't really realize who else
was in this but that one guy the guy
playing I think Vince Neil is the dude
from The Punisher series who is like the
really disturbed soldier guy who they
focus on for the season at least
definitely looked like him he must just
be part of the Netflix crew this feels a
little bit different to me than your
generic biopic Netflix crew like the
Netflix players yeah start off I was
thinking okay this looks like a generic
biopic movie like as it started but
there was something about this
seems to really commit to the
exploration of their lifestyle which
makes me a lot more intrigued because a
lot of times it Bob picks up my coat
yeah yeah but whenever we're actually
good people actually I when I when I
pulled up the trailer I think I saw on
the trailer page is this the motley crew
actual page says we can't wait for you
guys to see this exclamation mark the
YouTube channel has 154,000 it could be
their social media manager handling yeah
it's the bad it got back together
I mean Nikki Sixx is already on the
radio at night talking to Kerri Kasem so
why not just start a podcast there seems
to be a lot of those shots of like GoPro
strapped I'm just going crazy you know
it seems like they probably really want
you to do I mean this is an opportunity
yet to shove you into again that
notoriously quintessential rock and roll
lifestyle so I have to imagine they do
want you in the shoes because what other
opportunity are you gonna get to be
transported into that life yeah I know
and and at the rate of risk at which
they lived that life time is told based
on the comments it seems like a lot of
people are hoping this will just out do
Bohemian Rhapsody in every way possible
because this was a very different story
well I think maybe a Rap City let people
down and the in the sense of doesn't
explore the lifestyle to the degree it
could have where is this they're even
advertising this one was saying based on
the best-selling book and usually with
you know autobiography or biopic books
they go hardcore detail about their
lifestyle I think of like scar tissue of
Anthony Kiedis of the Chili Peppers just
get this insight into their drug abusive
lifestyle I'm kind of hoping they really
commit to this and if it's Netflix they
should be able to this would be fun to
be a good time I'm gonna watch it yeah
oh you have children and it's nice to
watch it late at night I'll probably
watch it in arts watch it with them on
there bro okay yeah yeah sit him down
close to the
[Laughter]
drugs kids don't do drugs hey speaking
of not doing drugs you know who doesn't
do drugs I don't
breanne ship and also our patron
Niraj Krishnan paid to the day shoutout
for this beautiful bastard wanted to
make sure we shot it out in this video
Niraj Krishnan is a huge music lover one
of our loyal patrons one of our loyal
followers he's always trying to hit up
John to get him to react to the music
videos he wants him to react to John
doesn't respond quick enough he hates
John now I have to deal with the
messages I'm like dude take it up with
Johnny it's like well no clearly John
doesn't respond to me so I'm gonna talk
to you Greg I'm like ROG get off my ass
all right get off my ass but stay
pledged to the patron page yeah morning
Garage just this on the shout yeah I'll
show you out of the patreon page no
cards but stay keep your credit card on
file yeah you deserve this treatment all
right we don't need the money but we do
subscribe to the region click that
notification about Brianne Chandler
where can the boys and the 15% of the
girls who watch this channel follow you
you can find me on instagram miss
underscore movies or you can look at
archives of what I've done previously on
my channel miss movies archives archives
I don't have anything like current is
what I'm saying see have like an
archived playlist well I mean it's like
everything I've done previously it just
stays there oh you mean like you're all
busy I think you're talking about like
every collab you've ever done is work
you put together
Washington DC in 1995 slideshows alright
take care now bye bye then name that
movie